et opération de sensibilisation à
destination des motards ce matin sur la
route nationale 10 entre trapèze
essarts-le-roi unités de sécurité
routière de la police nationale étaient
présentes à l'origine de cette opération
la direction départementale de la
sécurité publique des yvelines
l'objectif n'était non pas de verbaliser
les cyclomoteurs mais de les
sensibiliser à l'expérimentation et aux
règles de la circulation inter files mis
en place depuis le mois de février 2016
cette pratique implique de respecter
certaines règles la circulation inter
files est limitée à 50 km heure en ville
et reste interdite en ville et sur les
routes non séparées par un terre-plein
central on écoute tout de suite les
réactions d'un moteur ainsi que celle de
frédéric frémont commissaire de police
en charge de l'opération une bonne chose
c'est bien de
de faire prendre conscience aux motards
qu'il faut faire attention même en
passant entre les voitures moi je pense
surtout que c'est
c'est plutôt aux autres usagers eux
les prévenir que maintenant enfin les
motards ont le droit
selon certaines
disposition de pouvoir passer entre les
files de voitures on est là aujourd'hui
on leur rappeler que les remonte et ils
se font dans des conditions assez
précises leur rappeler aussi que dans ce
département nous avons certes une baisse
du nombre global des morts depuis deux
ans et c'est une grande satisfaction
nous avons encore un ratio de 45 % des
tués qui sont des tués qui étaient des
conducteurs de deux roues donc on
profite cette circulation inter files à
l'essai pour rappeler aussi que dans ce
département les motocyclistes sont des
usagers vulnérables